The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOM LEIGHTON: Today
we're going to talk
about the concept
of independence.
In probability, we
say that an event A
is independent of an event B
if one of two conditions hold.
First, if the
probability of A given B
is just the same as
the probability of A
or if B can't happen, namely
the probability of B is 0.
In other words, A is independent
of B if knowing that B happened
doesn't change the probability
that A is going to happen.
So knowing that
this event occurs
doesn't influence the
probability that A occurs.
And there's a special case where
they're independent because you
know that B can't happen.
If the probability
of B happening is 0,
then everything is
independent of B.
Now, the typical
example that gets used
is when you flip two coins.
So say we flip two
fair, independent coins.
And let's let B be the event
that the first coin is heads
and that means that the
probability of B happening
is 1/2, because we've
assumed it's a fair coin,
and we'll let A be the event
that the second coin comes out
heads.
So we know the probability of
A is 1/2 because it's fair.
And because they're
independent, we
can conclude that the
probability of A given B
is 1/2, which is the probability
of A. In other words,
seeing the result
of the second coin
doesn't tell you anything about
the result of the first coin.
Now actually, when
you flip two coins,
it's not just always the
case if they're independent.
Can anybody think
of an example where
you can flip a pair of coins
and they are dependent somehow,
they're not independent?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you have to
get two heads and two tails?
TOM LEIGHTON: If you have to
get two heads or two tails.
Well, how would you have to get?
AUDIENCE: The probability
of getting two heads
should be 1/4 [INAUDIBLE].
TOM LEIGHTON: Well,
then they would
be independent in that case.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you glue
the coins together.
TOM LEIGHTON: Yeah.
I mean, this is a silly example,
but I got two fair coins here.
I could clip them together
and now I flip them
and odds are pretty good they're
both going to be heads or both
be tails.
If you know what happened
to the right coin,
it will tell you what
happened to the left coin.
Now, that's a pretty
contrived example,
but it is illustrative of
what happens in practice.
In practice, we
assume independence
even though there can
be subtle dependencies
and this could lead to trouble.
In fact, we're going to
give a lot of examples
where it leads to
trouble today and also
for the rest of the course.
Because we're always going to
want to assume independence
and when we do, we're going
to get very nice results,
but things aren't always
independent in practice
and establishing independence
is a hard thing to do.
For that matter, while
we're on the subject,
we always talk about fair coins.
You flip a coin and it's fair.
You know, that's not
always to either.
There's actually a
famous mathematician
named Persi Diaconis who used
to down the street at Harvard
and he came and
gave a talk one day
at MIT in the math department
and he's a probabalist.
He does probability theory
and is a very cool guy.
And so he flipped a coin,
got a quarter from somebody
in the audience and
flipped it and he
flip that I think 10 or
20 straight times all
the way to the roof,
caught it, turned it over.
Every time it was heads.
And he goes, now what's the
probability of that happening?
Well, you know, it's 1/2
to the 20th or whatever,
not very likely.
How could he always
make it come out heads?
Well, Persi was an unusual
guy and in fact, he'd
spent months in the strobe
lab over at Harvard practicing
to make it always rotate seven
times, three of them on the way
up, one at the top,
and then three down.
And he could actually
see how many rotations it
had done to make
sure it was seven,
so it always came out heads.
Now, he is an unusual fellow.
He was 1 of 10 people
in the world that
could do a perfect shuffle
reliably on a deck of cards
and that's a very
hard thing to do.
He said he had to practice 8
hours a day for over six months
to be able to do it every time.
In fact, he gave another
talk at MIT where he came in
and he made magic tricks,
actually based on mathematics.
And you would cut a deck,
he would feel it like this
and tell you where you
cut, how many cards
were in the part you picked
up and then do his eight
perfect shuffles, which
is enough to return
a normal 52-card deck back
to its original order.
And then using this,
he could play the game
where pick any card,
you stick it in,
he feels where the card went,
and then using mathematics,
he could shuffle
the deck eight times
and make the card come out
anywhere he wanted in the deck.
So he had a lot going
on upstairs too.
He had an interesting
life history.
He ran away from
home as a young child
and joined the traveling circus.
And then somehow from there, he
joined the faculty at Harvard.
You know, there's
an amazing story.
And actually your
story about Persi
is he was the first
guy to get kicked out
of casinos for card counting.
He figured that out way before
the MIT team and the movie 21.
Down in Puerto Rico,
he used to play
and then they finally figured
him out and he got booted.
So back to independence, let's
do another picture example.
Say that my sample
space looks like this
and I've got two events, A
and B and they look like this,
so they're dis-joined.
Are A and B independent?
No.
In fact what is the probability
of A given B as I've drawn it?
AUDIENCE: 0.
TOM LEIGHTON: 0.
Because if B occurs,
you're outside of A.
And so this does not
equal the probability of A
as long as it's not 0.
So disjoint events don't imply
that they're independent.
Now, what's the picture
look like for them
to be independent?
What is the right
picture to draw here?
So I got my sample
space and say I
make this half the sample
space be A. Well, then B
to be independent,
would look something--
I didn't quite draw it.
I actually have it be 50-50.
So if a is 50% of S,
like this half, then
for A to be independent of
B, A intersect B, this part,
has to be 50% of B. Because
the probability of A given B
must equal the probability
of A to be independent.
So this would be a picture
where they are independent.
Now, independent
events are really
nice to work with and
in part because they
have a very simple
rule for computing
the probability of an
intersection of events
and it's called the product
rule for independent events.
And that says that if
A is independent of B,
then the probability of
A and B or A intersect B
is just the product
of their probabilities
separately, the probability of
A times the probability of B.
So let's prove this.
And there's two cases, depending
on whether or not B can happen,
if the probability
of B is 0 or not.
So case 1 is B can't happen.
The probability of B is 0.
In this case, what's the
probability of A and B?
B can't happen.
0.
If B can't happen,
then they both can't.
You can't have both
of them happening
and that equals the probability
of A times the probability of B
because the
probability of B is 0.
So that case works.
Case 2 is the probability
of B is bigger than 0.
In that case, we have
the probability of A
and B, A intersect B,
well, from the definition,
is the probability of B times
the probability of A given
B. We did that last time.
And by independence, this
is just the probability of A
because A is independent
of B, so we're done.
In fact, many texts
will define independence
by this product rule.
Many texts will say
that A and B are
independent if this is true.
And it's equivalent,
it turns out.
We won't prove that here, but if
you use this as the definition,
then you can derive our
definition as a result.
So this is an equivalent
definition of independence.
Another nice fact about
independent events
is that it's a
symmetric relationship.
It's called the symmetry
of independence.
That says that if they
A is independent of B,
then the reverse is true.
B is independent of A.
Now, we won't prove that.
It's actually easier
to see that it's true
if this were the
definition of independence
because A intersect
B is the same
as B intersect A and
multiplication is commutative.
So it's easier to see it if
we had used that definition.
So because of this
we often just say
A and B are independent
because it doesn't matter which
order you're taking them in.
All right, any questions
about the definition so far?
All right.
Let's do some examples.
Let's say I have two
independent fair coins.
And I'm going to
have the event A be
the situation when the coins
match, both heads, both tails.
And B is going to be the event
that the first coin is heads.
And I want to know, are
A and B independent?
Are those independent events?
Well, what's the
first answer to this?
I mean, A is event
the coins match.
B tells me what
the first coin was.
So the first inclination
here is that these
are dependent events
because I know something
about the first coin,
so that might tell me
something about the
probability they match.
There could be some
dependence here.
Now, in fact, because it's
set up, they're independent
and we can check that by
just doing the calculation,
computing the probability of A
given B. Maybe I can do that.
I'll do that here.
The probability of
A given B is, well,
the condition that they're
going to match given
that the first
point is heads means
it's the same as the
second coin being heads.
This is the probability the
second coin is heads and that's
just 1/2 because it's a
fair coin and independent
of the first one.
Now, the probability of A, by
itself, the events the coins
match, what's that?
How much is that?
What's the probability
the coins match?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM LEIGHTON: 1/4 plus 1/4.
I've got 1/4 chance
of heads, heads
1/4 chance of tails, tails,
so it's 1/2, so it works out.
The probability of A given B
equals the probability of A.
They're both 1/2.
So A and B are
independent events
because that's
just the definition
even though it looked like there
might have been some dependence
lurking around here.
Now, this example that I just
did is a little misleading.
The intuition they
probably are dependent
actually is good
intuition in this case
because if I don't have fair
coins, they are dependent.
All right.
So in particular,
let's look at what
happens if the probability
of a heads is p
and the probability of tails
is 1 minus p for both coins.
So let's compute the
probability of A given
B. What is it in this case?
Well, it's the probability
the second coin is heads.
What's that?
p because both of them are
heads with probability, p.
They're independent still.
The two coins are independent.
And now let's look
at the probability
that the coins match.
Well, it's a probability
of heads, heads
and the probability
of tails, tails.
Heads, heads is p times p.
Tails, tails is 1
minus p squared.
So to independent, I
need this to equal that
or to have the
probability of B be 0.
So A and B are
independent if and only
if-- the first
case is probability
B is 0, which means
that p equals 0,
or that has to equal this.
So p would have to equal 1
minus 2p plus 2p squared,
just square that out there.
So let's solve this.
That happens if and only
if 0 equals 1 minus 3p
plus 2p squared.
That's true if and only if
0 equals-- I factor this--
it's 1 minus 2p times 1 minus
p and that's if and only
if p is 1/2 or p
is 1, two roots.
So if the coins are always
heads, they're independent.
If they're always tails,
the events are independent
or if they're fair coins, these
two events are independent.
But anything else, they're
not independent anymore.
Any questions?
And now you can sort
of see if the coins are
likely to be tails
and the first one
comes up heads, that should
influence the probability
the coins match.
It should change.
Questions?
All right.
So there's a nice application
of this to getting
an edge in ultimate Frisbee.
Now, when you're
playing ultimate,
you've got to decide who
gets the Frisbee first.
And sometimes you don't have
a coin to flip, call heads
or tails, but you
do have the Frisbee.
Now, you could flip the Frisbee
and call right side up or not,
but the problem is the Frisbee
is known not to be a fair coin.
When you toss it
up in the air, it's
likely to wind up on, I
guess, the curved edge down.
So that wouldn't be fair
to call heads or tails.
So the standard solution
is to flip the two
Frisbees at the same
time or one Frisbee twice
and somebody calls
same or different,
that the two Frisbees both
come up on the same way
or they come up
different ways and then
if you called it right, you
get to start with a Frisbee.
And the idea behind this is
that that simulates a fair coin,
that the probability that
they're the same is 50-50.
What do you think.
Is that a fair way to
decide who starts first?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No.
TOM LEIGHTON: No.
Yeah, that's right.
It's not.
Now, it is in the case
when the coin was fair,
but we know the
Frisbee is not fair.
And in fact, you can see
this from this probability.
This is the probability
of a match, which
is fine at p equal
1/2, but in fact,
if you analyze
this equation, you
find out its minimum
value is at p equals 1/2
and as p starts moving away
from 1/2 towards 0 or to 1,
it gets bigger.
And we know that for
Frisbees, p is not 1/2.
This means that the probability
of a match is better than 50%.
So if you're ever
playing ultimate,
always call same
because you're going
to have a better than
50-50 chance of getting
to start with the Frisbee.
It's not a fair example.
There is another example
of how to make a fair coin
from a biased coin to an
unbiased coin in homework, ways
of doing this that are fair.
Because often you have
biased random numbers
and you want to get unbiased
or maybe you got a fair coin
and you want to make
something that comes up
heads with probability 1/3.
How do you actually do
that in a way that works?
Any questions on that?
The next example is from
the first OJ Simpson trial.
How many people here
know who OJ Simpson is?
OK, so he's still pretty famous.
Now, as you probably
know then he
was a famous football player.
Back when I was a kid, he
was a famous college player,
then he was a famous
pro player and then he
was an actor, famous actor.
And then he was accused of
murdering his wife in a gory
knifing and a friend
of his wife's.
And ultimately, the jury
found him not guilty,
but pretty much everybody in
the country thought he did it.
He looked really guilty.
And it was a big media event,
one of the first big trial
events on TV.
And so all the proceedings
were on TV and everybody
watched them.
We'd all go home to
watch the OJ hearing.
It was amazing.
Now, during the
indictment proceedings,
there was a huge dispute
over what independence
was and does it matter.
The issue arose when the
prosecution witness claimed
that only 1 in 200 Americans
had a certain blood type that
matched the blood type found at
the scene of the crime, which
was alleged to be OJ's blood.
And this was during
the indictment
and back then DNA
tests took a long time
and they weren't ready yet.
And the witness presented
the following facts and this
was the crime lab
guy, the police guy.
He said that 1 in 10 people,
roughly, matched type O blood.
And that 1 in 5 people matched
the Rh factor positive.
And that 1 in 4 people match a
certain kind of marker, which
I don't remember what it was.
We'll just call it marker XYZ,
some other factor of the blood.
And then this conclusion was
that this means that 1 in 200
match all three factors.
And this seems reasonable
because there's
1/10 of the people have O, if 15
of them have positive Rh factor
and then 1/4 of
all of those have
this marker, that's 1 in 200.
Now, it's important
because OJ's blood
and the blood at the crime
scene both matched all three.
So the implication,
of course, is
that OJ is looking like
the guy who did it.
And the question was, well,
is the 1 in 200 really true?
We can sample these
three in the populations
and see they're true, but
is 1 in 200 really true?
Now, it would be if,
in fact, we verified
that 1/5 of the
type O people have
positive and 1/4 of
the O positive people
have the XYZ marker.
But well, we don't necessarily
know that unless we
go figure that out.
If you assume
they're independent,
then it would be true.
The product rule will
tell us that if you
assume they're independent.
So during the trial, a special
math defense counsel showed up,
not part of the
normal defense team,
but he was brought in as
a mathematician and lawyer
and he crosses the
police guy on the stand.
And he asked the
police guy, the lab guy
if it is known that these
three factors are independent.
Well, the poor
police lab guy never
heard the word
independent before, didn't
know what it meant and the
defense counsel proceeded
to crucify him on the stand.
And then in the end, all
he could say was, look,
we just get these things
and we multiply them.
That's what we're
supposed to do.
It was a little scary.
The actual transcript--
you can still get it--
is a little scary.
The same problem arises
today with DNA testing.
Only there, you've got
lots of these things
and you multiply
them all together
and you get
probabilities like one
in many billion
probability of a match.
Now, there's probably a higher
level of science going on
with DNA testing,
but it's even harder
to really establish
independence.
If you assume it, fine.
The math works out great.
You just multiply them together.
But how do you know
it's really true?
How do you know that maybe a lot
of people that have those four
markers and DNA don't happen
to just have the fifth also,
but it really is
totally unrelated.
And to know that
for sure, you got
to test hundreds of millions of
people, which we really haven't
done yet, and not just
a few guys in Detroit
to be able to conclude
independence of 1
in a billion probabilities.
So for us, this is a lot easier.
In the classroom, we
assume independence
and we'll keep doing
that left and right,
but it doesn't mean
it's true in reality.
In fact, in the
last week of class.
We'll talk about how false
assumption of independence
on mortgage failures led to
the subprime mortgage disaster
in the recession.
It was all because of
some mathematics mistakes
that people made.
Now, this example
raises the question of,
what does independence mean when
you have more than two events?
We defined independence
when there is two events,
but here there's three.
And so to be careful, we
got to actually define
dependence among more than
two events and in this case,
we talk about the events as
being mutually independent.
So let me define that.
So if I've got events
A1, A2, up to An,
we say they are
mutually independent if,
and this is a little complicated
notation, but for all i
and for all sets j that
are subsets of the events,
but not including i,
then the probability
that the i-th event occurs
given that all the events
in the subset
occurred, is the same
as the probability of the i-th
event occurring by itself.
Or there's a special
case where the chance
the other events occur is 0.
In other words, a
collection of events
is mutually independent
if any knowledge
about any of the rest of the
events, happening or not,
does not influence the
event you're looking
at for each of those events.
So no information about
any of the other markers
the blood influences the
i-th marker for any i.
The probabilities are unchanged.
Now, there's an equivalent
definitions based
and the product rule.
Let me show you that version
because that's easier
to work with usually.
This is the product
rule form and it
says that A1, A2, up
to An are mutually
independent if for any
subset of the events
the probability of each of those
events in the subset happening,
all them happening,
is simply the product
of their individual
probabilities.
So independence
means that if you
want the probability of a
bunch of events occurring,
just multiply them
out individually.
And that follows
for independence
or it could be the
definition of independence,
depending on how
you want to do it.
So either of these
are good enough
for you to use as a definition
or a result for independence.
And so the blood guy, of course,
is just multiplying them out
because they're assumed
to be independent,
so it's OK that way.
Let's do an example.
So for example, say
we have three events.
A1, A2, and A3 are
mutually independent
if, these are the things
you have to check,
probability A1 and A2
is just the probability
of A1 times the
probability of A2.
Then you'd check that the
probability of A1 and A3
is the product of their
probabilities, A1 and A3.
And you'd check the
probability of A2
and A3 is the product
of their probabilities.
And there's one
more thing to check.
What's that?
All of them.
The probability of all of them
is the product of each of them
together here.
So if you want to show
the three events are
mutually independent, these
are the four things you check.
That's one way to do it, which
is the case of the blood typing
in the situation.
All right.
Let's do an example.
Well, for example, if
I flip three unbiased,
mutually independent coins.
The probability of two of
them being heads is 1/4.
The probability of three being
heads is 1/8 and so forth.
Let's do a trickier example.
This is a question that was on
the final exam a few years ago
and a lot of the
class missed it.
So now we'll do it here.
Say I flip three fair, mutually
independent coins and my events
are going to be A1 is the
event coin 1 matches coin 2.
The second event,
A2, is the event
that coin 2 matches coin 3.
And the third event,
A3, is the event
that coin 3 matches coin 1.
And the question was,
are these three events
mutually independent?
Prove your answer.
Let's try to figure that out.
The coins, of course,
are mutually independent,
but what about these events?
So let's start doing it.
What's the probability one
of the events occurring?
Well, you got to get the
two coins at hand to match,
so that's the
probability of a heads,
heads plus the probability
of a tails, tails.
That's 1/4 plus 1/4 equals 1/2.
Now, the probability of Ai
and Aj, i and j are 1 to 3,
they're different,
but what is a way
of characterizing that case?
Say event 1 occurred
and event 2 occurred,
how would I characterize that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All the same.
TOM LEIGHTON: All of them.
Yeah.
All of the coins are the same
because if A1 and A2 occur,
I know 1 matches
2 a 2 matches 3.
If A1 and A3 happen, 1
matches 2 and 1 matches 3,
so they're all the same
and the same for A2 and A3.
If 2 matches 3 and 3 matches
1, they're all the same.
So this is the same as saying
all three coins are the same.
It could all be heads
or all be tails.
And that's an 8
plus 8, which is 1/4
and that means equals
the probability of Ai
times the probability
of Aj, which is
what I need for independence.
And then they said they're done.
They are independent,
the three events.
You like that answer?
What's missing?
The last case.
They didn't check
the last case and we
got to do that to have
mutual independence.
So let's look at that.
The last case is probability
A1 intersect A2 intersect A3.
What is the probability
that all three events occur?
Well, the coins all
have to match, right?
If all the coins match, all
three events occur, right?
And what's the probability
all 3 coins match?
1/4, just the same
as this, is 1/4.
Does that equal probability
of A1 times the probability
of A2 times the
probability of A3?
What's that?
1/8.
This is 1/8.
They are not equal.
They are not mutually
independent events.
All right?
Any questions about that?
It might well be something like
this on the final this year,
a good, decent chance.
So if you start going along,
looks like they're independent,
but you forget to check
that last case, which shows
they're not mutual independent.
So you've got to check for all
pairs and all subsets of events
for mutual independence.
Any questions about that?
Now, this is actually
an interesting example
because in this case, all
pairs were independent
and when that happens, we give
that a special name and it's
called pairwise independence,
not too surprising.
And that can be
useful because there's
many times where you do
get pairwise independence,
but not mutual independence.
So let me give you
that definition.
So a collection of
events A1 through An
are said to be
pairwise independent
if for all i and j,
where i doesn't equal j,
Ai and Aj are independent.
Now, as we saw in this
example, in this example,
it was pairwise independence
because the probability
of Ai and Aj equaled the
probability of Ai times
the probably of Aj.
For any pair, it was true.
But it doesn't imply
mutual independence.
So pairwise does
not imply mutual.
Mutual would imply
pairwise because it's
true for every subset of events.
All right.
So let's go back for OJ and
see what would have happened.
What can you say about
the probability of a blood
match for a random
person if you only
knew that these factors
were pairwise independent?
Say you only knew that.
You didn't know they were
mutually independent,
but you knew they were pairwise
independent in the population.
What's the best you can
say about the probability
a random person matches that
blood profile, an upper bound
on the probability?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 1 in 50.
TOM LEIGHTON: 1 in 50.
Yeah.
So what you can say is 1
in 50, but nothing better.
So let's see why 1 in 50 works.
So let's let M1 be the
event you match here,
M2 be the event you
match their, and M3
be the event you match that.
The probability you
match all three is
upper bounded by
the probability you
match the first two
because matching all three
is a subset of this.
Pairwise independence
means that this is true.
This equals the
probability of matching
the first times the probability
of matching the second.
The probability of
matching the first
is 1/10, probably of
matching the second is 1/5,
so this is 1/50.
And you picked the best two.
You could have picked these two
and said it was at most 1/20
or those two and said
it's at most 1/40.
But you were clever and said,
OK, I'm going to take these two
and use that as my upper
bound, which is 1/50.
And it might well be that 1
in 50 people match all three.
That can well be.
Because maybe whenever you're O
positive, you have marker XYZ.
That's possible, potentially,
unless we find out otherwise.
What if I tell you can't
assume any independence at all?
What can you say about the
probability of a blood match
here for a random person?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 1/10.
TOM LEIGHTON: What is it?
TOM LEIGHTON: 1/10.
Because if they
match all three, they
match this and that probability
is 1/10, so it's at most 1/10.
And it could be
that everybody who's
O is O positive and has XYZ.
So unless you have
more information,
that's the best you can say.
It might well be
that's the answer.
Any questions about that?
So the assumptions
really matter.
The more independence
you assume,
the better bounds and the
probability you get of a match.
It's a little bit
unrelated to this,
but there was another
mathematics dispute
at the OJ trial.
It turned out the that
OJ had been beating up
Nicole on a fairly regular basis
and there were police records
because after he'd
beat her up, she'd
go in and complain
to the police.
And the prosecution wanted this
evidence admitted at the trial
because if the guy
is a wife beater,
it makes you think that
maybe he killed her.
And the defense lawyers argued
against admitting that evidence
because it wasn't tied to the
actual murder scene in any way
and they argued it would
be prejudicial to the jury
because, of course, if the jury
hears that OJ was beating her,
they might be more likely
to include to convict him
for murdering her.
Now, they got the
math council again
to argue that the reason
you shouldn't admit this
is because the
probability that you
kill your wife, that's K, given
that you batter your wife,
that's B, is 1 in 2,000.
I would have guessed
it was higher,
but the evidence did show that.
And so they said, look, there's
only a 1 in 2,000 chance
that this evidence of
wife beating is relevant
and therefore, it should not
be admitted because there's
a pretty decent chance
if the jury hears this,
they're going to convict him.
That's a pretty good argument.
And usually that kind of
thing, you exclude it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where did
that number come from?
TOM LEIGHTON: They got
some study and some experts
to come in and say that for
every 2,000 wife beaters,
only one of them
actually kills his wife.
Now, what do you suppose
the prosecution argued back?
They actually argued
back very effectively,
because that's a tough
argument to get by.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the probability
that you kill your wife
in the first place, that could
be 100 times larger than usual.
TOM LEIGHTON: Well,
that's a good point.
So maybe the probability
of killing your wife
not knowing B, I hope is
pretty small, probably
that's very small,
but I don't know.
But in any case, this
thing you're going from,
say it's 1 in 1 million
to 1 in 2,000, 1 in 2,000
is still too small to be used
as evidence that OJ did it.
AUDIENCE: Frequency he did it.
TOM LEIGHTON: Frequency,
they didn't get into that
because I guess he'd done it a
bunch, but that's a good point.
It could be there's
multiple beatings is higher.
Maybe that's 1 in 200 then.
In fact, that may be
the case because I think
there's probably they say
because if you do it once,
you do it multiple times.
So there's not much more
to be gaining there.
There's a critical
piece of information
we've left out of our
conditional probabilities here.
In fact, the most glaring
piece of all of evidence.
What's missing here?
What haven't we factored in?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The probability of B.
TOM LEIGHTON: The probability
of B, that's the battering.
Battering, I don't know what
it is, probably a large number.
Defense would argue
it's large, I guess,
but it shouldn't
matter that much.
AUDIENCE: The probability
that he actually beat her,
given that she threatened him?
TOM LEIGHTON:
Well, there's that,
but they have police--
well, that's true.
They didn't see him
doing it, but let's say
that they had good
evidence that he did it
and defense wasn't arguing
that he didn't really beat her.
The key thing we're missing
here is Nicole wound up dead.
She was dead.
And there's another stat here
that the prosecution argued.
So they argued this fact.
The probability the
husband kills his wife,
given that he batters her
and she wound up dead,
that somebody murder
her is bigger than 1/2.
So here M is somebody
murdered the wife.
Here, the husband beats her.
Now, the conditional
probability that he
killed her is bigger than
1/2 and that's a whopper.
Now, it's very relevant.
The probability
he killed her just
given that he beat her
is only 1 in 2,000,
but if you add the fact, which
is very relevant in this case,
that the wife was murdered,
this is now very compelling.
Now, in fact, they should
have really compare
this to probability he kills
her given that she's dead.
And so that would determine now
the relevance of the battering,
the wife beating.
That's what they should
have done, but they didn't.
They got this far and they
had that and the judge said,
I'm letting it in.
So it came in at that point.
But this would be the
right comparison, I think.
Because you look
at the probability
that you killed her
given that she's dead,
but now the additional
information, the wife
battering, how does that
change the probability?
And it probably
changes it materially.
So it's all a little
gory, but it's
interesting to see how
mathematics played out
in this kind of environment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are we supposed
to assume that he did
kill his wife?
TOM LEIGHTON: Yes,
and they assumed that,
but when you decide whether
or not to admit evidence,
if it's prejudicial, you've got
to have a really good grounds
to get it in.
Like if the evidence is going to
make the jury think he did it,
then you really got to argue the
evidence is relevant somehow.
There's material
information and that's
what the fight was about.
A 1 in 2,000 relevance
isn't going to cut it.
1 in 2, that's probably
pretty relevant.
And that will be
the grounds on which
the judge makes his decision.
But yeah, you assume
he didn't do it.
All right.
Back to independence.
So the last example today is
derived from a famous paradox
and has several actually
important applications
in computer science.
And this problem is known
as the birthday problem
or the birthday paradox.
It's a paradox because it sort
of has a surprising answer.
Probably a lot of
you have seen this
before in some form or another.
In the birthday problem,
there are N birthdays
and typically
we're going to look
at the case where N is
365, the days of the year,
and there is M people.
And for example, know maybe
there's 100 people here.
And what we want to know
is, what is the probability
that two or more people
have the same birthday.
For example, how
many people think
there's at least a 50%
chance that a pair of you
in the audience here
have the same birthday?
That's good.
How many people think there's
a better than 90% chance?
A few of you.
All right.
How many people think there's
a better than a 99% chance
that there's a pair
of matching birthdays?
A couple left.
How many think it's better
than a 99.9% chance?
We've got one, two.
You guys are going
to be stubborn.
Another one.
All right.
How many people think it's
more than 99.999% chance?
Actually it's six 9's.
It's incredible.
It is a virtual certainty.
So let's see.
In fact, the chance that
you're all different is about 1
in 3 million chance that
you're all different.
And we're going to see
why that's true here.
But to do that, we're
going to need to make
two important assumptions.
Any ideas about what assumptions
you're going to need?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Birthdays are
uniformly distributed.
TOM LEIGHTON: Birthdays
are uniformly distributed.
Any other ideas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: He stole my answer.
TOM LEIGHTON: Oh,
he stole yours.
What else are you going
to need to assume?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All birthdays are
independent of each other.
TOM LEIGHTON: Yeah.
Mutually independent.
We're going to
need that as well.
Now, in actuality, neither
is true in reality.
It's well known
that birthdays tend
to follow seasonal
patterns and they're
related to major events.
Now, do you all remember the big
blackout that hit the Northeast
several years ago?
Do you remember that?
Well, it turns out,
this is a true fact,
there were a lot of babies
born nine months later.
In fact, they had a name.
They're called blackout babies.
If you were born in that period
in the Northeast and there's
all these news stories about
the life of the blackout babies.
And the same thing happens
after cold snaps in the winter
and you get a blizzard
or this kind of a thing.
Nine months later,
you get babies.
In fact, I had a personal
experience with this.
Well, my son was born
on October 18, 1996.
And on the day he was born,
we're going to the hospital
and it was a zoo.
The maternity ward
was totally full.
We had to go at some other
wing of the hospital.
And babies were popping
out all over the place.
And I asked, what is going on?
Why don't you have enough
room for all the mothers here?
And they said, oh, it's
all the blizzard babies.
And I go, what?
And they go, well, remember
the blizzard of '96?
It's like, oh yeah.
I remember.
Yeah.
It was nine months prior
is the big blizzard
and so it's all the
blizzard babies coming.
So they're not uniform.
They're all different
probabilities here,
but we're going to assume
they're equally likely.
Now, independence is also
not true, in general.
What's one way that birthdays
might not be independent?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Twins.
TOM LEIGHTON: Twins.
So if they're twins, they
have the same birthday.
Now, there's other ways.
In fact, my only
sibling, my brother,
has the same birthday I do,
but I'm two years older,
so we weren't twins.
Now, you say, what
are the odds of that?
Well, 1 in 365, you think.
Well, one day I'm
in middle school,
about the age you start
thinking about these things,
and you get the idea to
count back nine months
from your birthday.
Probably some of
you have done that.
And I did that and
that's my dad's birthday.
I was like, oh.
May is not 1 in 365.
It's like, Happy Birthday.
I don't know.
Anyway, I almost needed to
go into therapy after that,
you know.
So now you all got to count back
nine months from your birthday.
Anybody whose birthday is on
September 30 or October 1,
nine months back
is New Year's Eve.
That's dangerous.
So in reality, birthdays
are not independent
and they are not
randomly distributed,
but we're going to
assume that because we're
going to use this same analysis
for computer science problems
where things are, hopefully,
more independent and random.
Now, we're going
to do an experiment
to see how many people
it takes us to get
a pair of matching birthdays.
So I'm going to run through
people in order in the rows
here, get your birthday
and we're going to record
and we're going to see how
far we go until there's
a match in that group.
So I will write up
the months here.
And we'll start with my
birthday is October 28.
So let's go right across.
What yours?
AUDIENCE: April 1.
TOM LEIGHTON: April 1.
OK.
We won't embarrass you here.
OK, who's next?
What's your birthday?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
September 2.
TOM LEIGHTON: September 2.
All right.
Yours.
AUDIENCE: June 1.
TOM LEIGHTON: June 1.
OK.
We'll come back.
AUDIENCE: April 8.
TOM LEIGHTON: What is it?
TOM LEIGHTON: April 8.
All right.
AUDIENCE: November 20.
TOM LEIGHTON: November 20.
AUDIENCE: June 12.
TOM LEIGHTON: June 12.
AUDIENCE: December 29.
TOM LEIGHTON: December 29.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM LEIGHTON: What is it?
AUDIENCE: June 14.
TOM LEIGHTON: June 14.
Ooh, I almost got one there.
That one's close.
All right.
What's yours?
AUDIENCE: March 6.
TOM LEIGHTON: March 6.
AUDIENCE: May 2.
TOM LEIGHTON: May 2.
AUDIENCE: 17th of November.
TOM LEIGHTON: November 17.
Close again.
AUDIENCE: August 4.
TOM LEIGHTON: August 4.
AUDIENCE: July 25.
TOM LEIGHTON: July 25.
I don't think we'll get
to 100 here, hopefully.
Yeah, what's yours?
AUDIENCE: October 30.
TOM LEIGHTON: What is it?
TOM LEIGHTON: October 30.
Got close.
AUDIENCE: July 6.
TOM LEIGHTON: July 6.
All right.
AUDIENCE: February 25.
TOM LEIGHTON: February 25.
AUDIENCE: May 21.
TOM LEIGHTON: May what?
21st of May.
AUDIENCE: May 30.
TOM LEIGHTON: May 30.
You guys fooled me.
What have you got?
AUDIENCE: January 12.
TOM LEIGHTON: January 12.
All right.
AUDIENCE: July 14.
TOM LEIGHTON: July 14.
OK.
AUDIENCE: April 30.
TOM LEIGHTON: April 30.
AUDIENCE: March 13.
TOM LEIGHTON: March 13.
All right.
Did I get--
AUDIENCE: October 7.
TOM LEIGHTON: October 7.
AUDIENCE: October 8.
TOM LEIGHTON: Ah, you guys.
OK.
Did I get you?
AUDIENCE: September 15.
TOM LEIGHTON: September 15.
AUDIENCE: November 9.
TOM LEIGHTON: November 9.
All right.
AUDIENCE: July 15.
TOM LEIGHTON: July 15.
Close.
AUDIENCE: September 3.
TOM LEIGHTON: September 3.
You guys are killing me here.
AUDIENCE: February 6.
TOM LEIGHTON: February 6.
AUDIENCE: October 26.
TOM LEIGHTON: OK.
AUDIENCE: November 2.
TOM LEIGHTON: November 2.
AUDIENCE: January 23.
TOM LEIGHTON: January 23.
AUDIENCE: September 27.
TOM LEIGHTON: You guys are going
to set a record for sure here.
This isn't the way
it's supposed to go.
AUDIENCE: December 30.
TOM LEIGHTON: December 30.
AUDIENCE: December 28.
TOM LEIGHTON: Ah, come on, guys.
What is the probability
of going this long here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: September 22.
TOM LEIGHTON: September 22.
AUDIENCE: July 30.
TOM LEIGHTON: July 30.
AUDIENCE: The 24th of August.
TOM LEIGHTON: 24th August.
I'm going to have to ask
the same person to tell me
twice here to get a match.
We got over there now?
AUDIENCE: April 6.
TOM LEIGHTON: April 6.
AUDIENCE: October 16.
TOM LEIGHTON: October 16.
AUDIENCE: Did ask how many--
AUDIENCE: September 3.
TOM LEIGHTON: September 3.
All right.
Very good.
Let's count and see
how many we got here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20
21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28,
29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36,
37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42.
That is a record.
So it took 42 people
to get a match.
Now it turns out that
for N equals 365,
the magic number for N
is 23, that by 23 people,
we got a 50-50 chance.
In fact, the probability of a
match on 23 people is 0.506.
It's a little bit better
than 50-50 chance at 23.
Now, maybe we should figure out.
It's too late for
homework to figure out
what the chances are of going
this long without a match.
That maybe worth
figuring that out.
Now, it may seem
surprising at first
that 23 people is
enough to have a 50/50
chance because the chance of
any pair matching is 1 in 365,
by our assumption.
And that's small, but there's
lots of pairs of people
and every pair of people
have a chance to match
and that's why 23 turns out
to be enough to get to 50-50.
Now, we're going to do the
analysis for general M and N
to the figure out the
probability of a match
if there's M people
and N birthdays.
There's lots of ways to do it.
The easiest is to sort of well,
we'll draw the sample space.
It will be too big to
draw the whole thing,
but we can sort of
model the sample space
and then look at
the sample points.
So you've got the first person
and there's N birthdays here,
so it could be anywhere from
January 1 out to December 31
and in general this
will be N. And then you
have the second person and
they have N possibilities
for their birthday.
And you take the tree down M
levels to the very last person
here.
So each node has degree N and
there's M levels on this tree.
So the sample space is the set
of all n-tuples b1, b2, to bm,
these are the birthdays
where every value of bi
is between 1 and N. So a sample
point is all the birthdays
of the M people.
How many sample
points are there here?
Remember how to
count these things?
Number of leaves on an
N-ary tree of depth M or you
can think of it this way.
I've got N choices for each
bi and there's M of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TOM LEIGHTON: So what's the
number of sample points?
AUDIENCE: N to the M.
TOM LEIGHTON: N to the M.
Because N choices here,
N choices here, N
choices there, so you
have N times N times N M times.
And what's the probability
of each outcome?
For a set of possible birthdays,
what's its probability?
What's the probability
of b1, b2, bM?
So the probability
of a sample point.
What's the probability that the
first person has birthday b1,
the second has b2,
and the N-th has bM?
Remember that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 1 over N to the M.
TOM LEIGHTON: 1 over N to
the M because each edge
is probability of 1
over N and the paths
are length M, so you've got
1 over N to the M-th power.
Probability of the first
birthday matching is 1 in N
times 1 in N times 1 in N.
And this actually makes sense
because I've got N to
the M sample points,
each a probability
1 over N to the M.
So they all add up
to 1, which is good.
What kind of sample
space is this
where this happens where all
the probabilities are the same?
AUDIENCE: Uniform.
TOM LEIGHTON: Uniform.
Makes it very easy to work with.
All we got to do
now is just count
the number of
sample points where
there's a matching birthday and
then we multiply by that one
probability 1 over N to the M.
Now, it turns out that
rather than counting
the number of sample
points where there's
a matching birthday,
it's easier to count
the number of sample points
for all the birthdays are
different.
And this is often the case
when you're doing a counting
problem, it's easier
to count the opposite
of what you're after.
That can be the case
and it is the case here.
So we're going to do that.
So let's count how many
sample points are all
different birthdays, so no
pair of bi's is the same.
Let's do that.
How many choices
are there for b1?
365 or N. Let's do
this in terms of N
because we're going to
use this for general N.
How many choices for b2?
N minus 1.
Given you are the first
one, you can't match it.
And then N minus 2 all the
way over to the last one
is N minus M plus 1.
And this is a formula
you should all remember.
That's just N factorial
over N minus M factorial.
You did this sort of stuff a
couple weeks ago with counting
sets and probability is really--
a lot of it's about counting.
So now we can compute
the probability
that all the birthdays
are different.
It's just adding up all the
sample points of which there's
n factorial over N minus
M factorial and multiply
by the probability
of each one, which is
1 over N to the M. All right.
So we've actually now
answered the question.
This is the probability that
all the birthdays are different.
The only problem is,
it's not so clear
what the answer is to
actually compute this
or how fast it grows.
So if I wanted to get
a closed form for this
without the factorials,
what do I do?
What do I use?
Stirling's formula.
So let's remember that.
It says that N factorial
is asymptotically equal
to square root 2 pi N
times N over e to the N.
And that is accurate within
0.1% when N is at least 100.
So not only is it
asymptotically equal,
it's right on track for
a reasonable size N.
Now, I won't drag you
through all the calculations.
I used to actually try
plugging that formula
in for here and
here and then going
through all the calculations,
but we won't do it in class.
It's in the text.
But I will tell you
where that winds up.
It's not hard, you've just
got to do the calculation.
So this is means the probability
that all birthdays are
different turns out to be
asymptotically equal to e
to the N minus M plus 1/2 times
the natural log of N over N
minus M minus M. And that's
accurate to within 0.2%,
if N and N minus M are
large, larger than 100.
So in fact, it's almost equal.
And now you could plug in N
equals 365 and M equals 100.
So if you do that, in fact,
if somebody has a calculator,
we should plug in,
what do we have, 42.
You should plug in
M equals 42 and see
what the probability is.
But if M is 100, the chance
that we're all different,
this equals 3.07 dot, dot,
dot times 10 to the minus 7.
And we should check
for M equals 42.
My guess is it's pretty
small, but I don't know.
We'll have to check that.
AUDIENCE: 0.0859.
TOM LEIGHTON: Great.
So a 9% chance of having 42
people all miss is a 9% chance.
So we were little unlucky.
That won't happen very often.
But when you go from 42 to
100, it gets really small.
1 in 3 million or so.
Now, if N is 365 and M
is 23, the probability
comes out to be about
0.49, so about 50-50,
they're all different.
Now.
For general M and
N, we'd like to know
when do you get to
the 50-50 point?
We'd like to derive an
equation for M in terms of N
where the probability of being
all different is about 1/2.
All right.
So let's do that.
So as long as we assume--
and this will turn out
to be true-- that M is a
little o of N to the 2/3
and remember little o means it
grows slower than N to the 2/3.
Then we can simplify
that expression
in asymptotic notation.
And when you do it, I won't
drag it through on the board.
It's also in the text, it
turns out to be much simpler.
It's just e to the
minus M squared over 2N.
So I take that
thing up there and I
assume that M is growing less
fast than the 2/3 power of N
and that whole upper
expression reduces down
to M squared over 2N.
Everything else goes
to 0 in the exponent.
Doesn't matter.
Now, if I set this
to be 1/2, I can
solve this to find out what M
has to be to make that be 1/2.
All right.
So this will be true if and
only if minus M squared over 2N
is equal to the
natural log of 1/2.
And that's true.
Take the minus sign, put it
inside to make a log of 2,
multiply by 2N.
That's true if M squared
equals 2N natural log of 2.
And now I can solve
for M really easily.
That's true if and
only if M equals
the square root of 2
natural log of 2N, which
is about 1.177 square root
of N. So for general N,
you get a 50% probability of
having a matching birthday when
M is in this range, pretty
close to 1.2 square root of N.
Now, this square root N
phenomenon, this thing here,
that's what's known as
the birthday principle.
It says if you've got roughly
square root of N randomly
allocated items into N
boxes or bins or birthdays,
there's a decent
chance two of the items
will go into the same bin
if the randomly allocated.
In this case, the bins
are the possible days
of the year that we put each
person into for their birthday.
Any questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: M and N
are like numbers
like they're defined up
there or does it mean
to say M equals [INAUDIBLE]?
TOM LEIGHTON: Yeah.
So here I looked at a
special case where N was 365,
M was 100, but we
can imagine them
as arbitrary numbers that
could be getting large.
And so over here and I say M
is little o of N to the 2/3,
I mean, well, M equals square
root of N would qualify.
Square root of N is
little o of N to the 2/3.
So as long as M is
not growing too fast,
I can simplify that expression
up there, which is what I did.
And then we go back
and we find, in fact,
the square root of
N the right answer
and that is little
o of N to the 2/3.
And I have to use a
different argument
if I assumed M was
bigger, which I didn't do.
I didn't drag it for that.
But I would have to
go check that case.
So we can think of general
is M and N as being
arbitrary variables and
potentially growing.
M can be a function
of N. And in fact,
when M is the square
root function of N, then
we got a 50% chance of a match.
Now, the birthday
principle comes up all
over the place in
computer science
and it's worth remembering.
For example, the
generic form for this
is when you have
a hash function.
Let's say I have a
hash function, h,
from a large set of items
into a small set of items.
For example, say I'm
computing digital signatures.
This is the space
of all messages,
this is the space of all
1,000-bit digital signatures,
and h is a digital
signature outcome.
Say I'm doing
memory allocations.
So all the things I might
be sticking into a register,
here's all the
places it could go.
Here's all the registers.
Error checking.
This is all the garbled
messages in the world.
This is the set of
messages that make sense,
all handled by functions,
random kind of functions often.
Now, what you worry about when
you're hashing is collisions.
Let me define that.
We say that x collides
with y if the hash of x
equals the hash of y, but
x and y are different.
For example, say you're
looking at digital signatures.
You would not want the
signature for a $100 check
to your mom to match your
signature for $100,000 check
to Boris.
Because that would be
bad because then Boris
could come in and take that
check to your mom for $100,
converted to a
$100,000 check to him
and the signature is
authentic if there's
a collision in the signatures.
So very important when
you're doing hash functions
and in many applications,
you don't want collisions
because all the whole
thing start breaking.
Memory allocation.
You don't want to assign two
things in the same place.
Error correction.
There's only one answer you
want to get out at the end.
Now, from the pigeon
hole principle,
you know if this set is
bigger than that set,
there is going to
be a collision.
That's what the pigeon
hole principle says.
Two guys will get mapped
to the same thing.
However, often in practice what
we care about is a subset L
prime of L that's pretty small
because the set of messages we
really assign is pretty small
compared to all 1,000-bit
signatures that are possible.
And what you'd like is that for
this smaller set of messages,
you might want to assign, they
all get mapped one to one.
And the birthday principle
says life is not so nice.
So let me write that
down then we'll be done.
All right.
So the birthday principle says
that if S is at least 100,
L prime is a subset of L that is
at least the square root of S.
So the cardinality of the
things you want to hash
is bigger than 1.2 square
root the cardinality of S.
And if the values of the
function h on L prime
are randomly chosen, uniform,
and mutually independent,
then there's at least
a 50% chance, so
with probability at least
1/2, there's a collision.
There exists an x and a y
such that x does not equal y--
and these are in L prime--
but h of x equals h of y.
All right.
The proof is not hard, it's
just we more or less did it.
You just plug in the
cardinality of L prime for M
and the cardinality of S
for N. And it's bad news
because it means it doesn't
take very many messages,
just square root the number of
signatures to get a collision.
You'd hope you could get that
you could have L prime be
as big as S and
that somehow they'd
all go one to one, that
everybody in this room
would have a different birthday.
That is not how it works
if things are random,
which is the case you
usually like to have.
Now, this technique is used to
crack cryptographic protocols
and it's called the birthday
attack based on the birthday
principle.
So what you do is,
you get a bunch
of messages that are
encrypted and pretty soon you
find two that get maybe
encrypted the same way.
And once you have that,
now you can go back
and crack the crypto system.
For example, you break schemes
like RSA with a birthday attack
if this space is not
big enough and that's
one reason why now RSA, the
keys have thousands of digits
because otherwise you
can use attacks like this
and crack them more easily.
Any questions about that?
OK.
Very good.
We're done for today.